today's questions from Ricky in
Washington he said David just can't gone
through my second beater car tired of
being on a first-name basis with the
triple a tow truck driver I'm out of
debt I have my emergency fund saved and
I have the money to get a little nicer
car having a hard time parting with it
because it works so hard to save it can
you talk a bit about the struggle people
have with spending money even when they
have it to spend yeah it's so hard to
finally get some in savings it's hard to
release it especially if you're wired as
a saver now I'm wired as a spender
my wife is wired as a saver you usually
we fall in one of two categories I think
you're wired as a saver she gets great
comfort from having that pile of money
more than she would get great comfort
from having a reliable car me I'd rather
have a reliable car past the emergency
fund you're at them you know this is an
emotional thing at this point it's not a
financial thing it's a I have the money
but I have trouble releasing it and so
what that says is you're just getting
some you know it's a normal thing and
it's not a bad thing but it's it just
says I get Security Act from that extra
money beyond my emergency fund and I'll
tell you this I I think it's something
we all have to work at one of our money
skills there's really three basic money
skills that you have spending properly
reasonably learning to enjoy money falls
under spending learning to enjoy life
with your money which is kind of what
your questions about the second one's
saving and learn to save money for
emergencies for college for retirement
to change your family tree to build
wealth and learn to invest you learn to
ride the investment waves like we've had
in the stock market in the last couple
weeks right and giving the power of
generosity to completely change you
when you learn to give as the natural
rhythm of your life it changes
everything
so giving saving and spending everyone
has at least one of those that they
struggle with - saving I'm a spender no
trouble for me to enjoy money it's also
no trouble for me to give money a lot of
spenders it's easy from them and be
generous because the the release of
money doesn't bother us as much as it
does a safer and if and so but I'm weak
at saving and that's why God makes me
teach this every day I'm no longer weak
at saving but it wasn't my natural
default I had to intellectually decide
to have an act of my will to save and
invest and really what drove me to do
that as a spender giver is that I would
have more to spend and give if I built
more wealth I can spend more and get
more and that's my only reason for
saving it's not because I just love
saving money
I still don't there's a day it's not
that so you're on the other side of this
Ricci is what we're saying
you know you you don't enjoy spending we
don't know about giving you didn't
address that in your thing sometimes I
can get spenders or savers like this to
turn loose of their money first by
increasing their giving and then that
kind of gives them permission to also
enjoy the money themselves but it would
be a shame to save and work and not
enjoy some of your money and one of the
things you should enjoy is a reliable
vehicle and you don't have a reliable
vehicle you've been drink you know
you've been doing beaters and so you you
know you need to go buy the car you
already knew that
you weren't asking about that but you
already knew that but maybe also take a
little bit of that money and give it
find someplace to be generous at your
church or find a couple that's
struggling or a single mom then
like bill for a year or whatever but
find something to do because there's
something about giving that kind of then
gives you permission down inside your
spirit to also enjoy money as money's
fun if you got some you ought to enjoy
it you don't enjoy some nice things now
if that's all you do and you don't save
you know give then you're just a shallow
tor right but you know to assume that
just because someone has the ability to
join and enjoy money means that they're
greedy or shallow that's just bogus and
the way you can tell is what percentage
of their financial situation is going
towards stuff of them and and if if all
the money you make is going to buy you
crap then then you're out of balance you
know but if you're if you're giving a
percentage of your income and you're
investing a good percentage of your
income and you're enjoying some of your
income on lifestyle purchases travel
cars clothes whatever it is then that's
in balance once you're at baby step
three and beyond and the end and that's
where Ricky is but it's a really good
question Ricky it's a good question for
me to stop and just kind of rant on or
vent on for a second here teach on for a
second because sometimes people think
well you know no one should ever have a
car like that why would anyone need a
house like that for now I've got a
friend that's worth about three billion
dollars now a billion is a thousand
million he has three thousand million he
has three thousand million he spent six
million on his house and people sent him
hate mail no I said I was like that his
house as a percentage of his net worth
and his income is like you going through
the drive-through at chick-fil-a and
buying a biscuit it didn't affect his
life one I own I'd have spent six
million dollars on a house as a matter
of fact that's a very conservative house
for someone who has three billion
dollars